بما انه كمان نحن مشاهدينا جالسين بنتكلم
عن البطولات النسائيه فعندنا نحن كمان
معانا بطله جديده شابه منوره شاشات رمضان
ميريتا الحلاني اللي في السنوات القليله
هذه طلت علينا كمغنيه واخر كم سنه شفناها
كمان ممثله وسنه بتشارك السباق الرمضاني
بمسلسل اسمه عشره عمر من بطولتها والفنان
جو صابر وهو اول مسلسل بدا عرض حلقاته قبل
رمضان بايام المسلسل بيحكي قصه بنت بسيطه
طيبه جميله اسمها بيريلا بيموتوا اهلها في
حادث ماساوي ولكن الام تحديدا وهي على
فراش الموت بتكشف سر خطير عن البنت ومن
هنا بتنطلق الاحداث الدراميه
[موسيقى]
صدقني ما راح اتركك رح ابقى حظك لو شو ما
عملت
المسلسل فهي ما حرمت الناس كمان من صوتها
وغنت تتر المسلسل
موجوع من غدر اغلى ناس موجوع
تقفل الاحساس
مكسور قلبي يا هوى وشوفي بعد اكتر
حتى الجرح ماله وكل يوم عم يكبر مكسور
قلبي وتنضم الينا الفنانه ماريتا الحلاني
اهلا فيكي معانا يا ماريتا وكل عام وانت
بالف خير يا رب
رمضان كريم لالك ولكل يلي عم بيحضرونا
ومبروك العمل كمان مبروك البطوله يعني عمل
واضح انه مميز والكل بدا يتابعوا قبل
رمضان هل في اي سبب انكم قررتوا يعني
تخرقوا العاده وتبداوا قبل رمضان
اول شيء مرتي كتير على الحكي الحلو قبل ما
سمعته كنت عم تحكي عنه يعني انبسطت كثير
بكلامك وان شاء الله يعني الناس تحب العمل
ونحن بلشنا قبل بوقت لانه المسلسل من اكثر
من 30 حلقه صحيح اوكي فانتم كنتم عاملين
حساب انه على نهايه رمضان بتخلصوا عادي
لانكم بتكونوا بادئين من قبل يعني
صاح ويمكن يبقى يعني ايام العيد كمان يعني
معقول اوكي طيب ايش اللي جذبك في هذا
العمل مريتا
هلا انا اول ما قرات الناس حبيت القصه
كتير يعني قصه قصه
بنت متبنينه مضيعه امها يعني في قصه شي
جديد لالي يعني ما بيشبه الاعمال يلي
قدمتها قبل والشخصيه بيرلا كمان شخصيه
مختلفه
فحسيت انه انه ليش لا يعني حلو شارك بهذا
العمل
وبالاخر النتيجه حتى كتير مبسوطه يعني هلا
عم بحضر ومبسوطه كتير ومبسوطه بتفاعل
الناس كمان
لانه في دراما كثير يعني مع كل حلقه جالسه
الدراما بتزيد اكثر واكثر بس كمان اللافت
طبعا كمان في العمل امريكي وانت قبل كده
مشاركه في اعمال اللي هي اللي بيسموها
المشتركه يعني السوريه اللبنانيه هذا
العمل عمل لبناني انت كنت حريصه يعني انه
تشاركي في عمل لبناني كنوع من الدعم
الدراما اللبنانيه ولا انه لا الموضوع
عادي حسب ما يجي يعني العمل
هلا هو اكيد بيجي عروض وانا بقرا بهمنا
اول شيء النص بهمنا دوري بهمني كتير
العوامل يعني بتاثر وبحب كمان كون عم اقدم
شي مختلف ما كنا عم باخد نفس الدور مثلا
وكمان لانه انتاج لبناني ومع شركه مروه
جروب للاستاذ مروان حداد يلي هو اعطاني
اول فرصه بطوله وقت تصورنا مسلسل حكايتي
وانعرض سنه الماضي فانا حبيت كرر هالتجربه
معه وكمان الظروف يلي عنا بلبنان يعني حلو
نشوف انه في شركات بعدها عم تقدم اعمال
والناس يعني عم تحضر فاكيد يعني في دعم
هون كمان مسلسل
تفضلي
كنت عم بقول انه قبل بارلو عشره عمر صورت
مسلسل اسمه نزيف كان مشترك يعني فيه كان
معنا ممثلين كبار سوريين كمان من العراق
فصورت هيك وهيك ما عندها مشكله ايوه هو ما
عندك مشكله وكان هذا الشيء كمان واضح حتى
في عشرين عشرين والكلام هذا كله وحقق دورك
وقتها يعني صدى كبير جدا بس لا زالت الناس
بتقول انه الاعمال المشتركه انجح واكثر
انتشارا بتتفقي مع هذا الشيء
لا انا برايي في كتير قصص بتاثر على
الموضوع بس اوقات بتلاقي عمل مشترك وعليه
انتاج ضخم ناس ما بتوصل لقلوب الناس ولا
ما حتى بتاخد اكسبورجر او يعني اوقات بكون
عمل بسيط وهيك مشتغلين عليه بانتاج اقل بس
كمان بيوصل يعني منه شرط هذا الحكي
وهالاعمال يلي بتنعرض على التلفزيون
بكونوا الناس يلي منهم قادرين يشتركوا
مثلا بمنصات على المنصات بكونوا عم
بيحضروها ببيوتهم يعني نحن عم نفوت على
بيوت الناس فكمان في لذه يعني بهذا
الموضوع وليه غنيتي تحديدا التتر في
المسلسل هذا التتر كتير حلو او على فكره
يعني
ثانكيو
ثانكيو هلا انا بما انه بغني يعني ليش لا
ما غني كمان تتر المسلسل
والممثلين اللي كانوا كانوا حابين انه انه
انا اغني ولا استاذ مروان اكيد المنتج
وانا فاهمه المسلسل يعني يكون فاهم
الشخصيات والقصه فغنيتها من كل قلبي
للغنيه يعني
وحسيتها كتير
وان شاء الله تكون وصلت كمان لقلوب الناس
لا وصلتوا صراحه انا جدا عجبتني يعني
صراحه اني صرت بسمعها بمعزل عن المسلسل
صرت بسمعها كاغنيه تقدر تغني مقطع منها
ولا ما بتحبوا حلو
الناس اللي هني قراب ما تصدقون كلهم حتى
الصدق
كذاب على الغدر
بيدلون الناس اللي
قراب ما تصدقون كلهم حتى الصدق
كذاب على الغدر بيدل
خلينا نقول لك لموضوع ثاني كمان حلو جدا
انت ان شاء الله يعني خلينا نقول انت
عروسه عشرين ثلاثه وعشرين خلينا نشوف بس
لقطات سريعه من احتفال بخطوبتك
[موسيقى]
يا اللي بتستحق
اعطي قلبي
[موسيقى]
بنرجع طبعا للعروس مريتا الف مبروك الف
مبروك مثل الفرح
شكرا شكرا ميرسي
متى الفرح ان شاء الله
نعم مثل الفرح الفرح يعني
كيف كانت الاحاسيس يعني شفنا الاحتفال فيك
وكده وحسينا انه يعني طبعا والدك كل
التحيه له طبعا كل التحيه لعائلتك يعني
كلهم نجوم بس حسينا والدك يعني جدا متاثر
كيف كان تقبله لانه في عريس جاي ياخذ بنته
يعني اكيد البيه بتعرفه بيكون معلق
باولاده يعني بنته بالاخص وانا اول بنت
واول حدا بيتزوج بالبيت
فصعبه لاله انه عم بترك البيت وبحس يعني
ما فينا كتير نحكي بالموضوع لانه بنتاثر
اكيد بحس هو يعني بفضل انه يلا ما ضروري
كثير نفوت بالتفاصيل بس مبسوط يعني بحبه
كثير لانه لخطيبه كميل هو بيحبه كثير
ومبسوط فينا يعني هلا هلا تقبل الموضوع
اكثر واكثر بعد الخطبه خلص صار بلش يفرح
اكتر
قدامه الموضوع صار لازم شويه يتقبل يعني
هي مشاعر مختلطه بيننا بين الفرح لا يعني
مبسوط لالي انا لقيت شخص المناسب وعم بكف
عامل حياه حلوه وبانه هو زعلان انه يشتاق
له يعني انا قلت له راح ضل عندك كمان راح
ضل اكيد طبعا ما في ما في بنت بتترك يعني
اكيد تابعت الاهتمام اللي صار شفنا
الفيديوهات
الاحتفال في الخطوبه صارت رد كل شيء صار
ترند ملابسك ملابس اختك ملابس مامتك كل
احد في ناس اتكلموا على الفستان اللي كنتي
لابستيه قالوا انه مريتا كانت لابسته في
فيديو كليب من قبل هل هذا الكلام صحيح
وبعدين عملوها انه كيف مريتا بتعيد
الملابس يعني حسسونا انه الموضوع عيب وانه
ما حد بيعيد الملابس ابدا وكلنا جالسين
بالعيد ملابسنا يعني بس انه بدي اياك يعني
بس تتكلمي عن هذا الموضوع اذا تردي عليهم
هلا اكيد اول شيء انبسطت كثير بكل التهاني
يعني كل الرسائل اللي وصلتني من الناس
واهتمامهم محبطهم الكبيره وبموضوع الفستان
انا عارفه انه لبسته من قبل ولبسته مره
لانه فستان بحبه وما عندي مشكله يعني
فستان موجود عندي وبحبه بلبسه وما فيك ترد
الناس يعني دائما بضل في شيء بده ينقال
يعني اذا لبستي شيء جديد بدهم يحكوا اذا
لبستي شي لبستي بدهم يحكوا فانه مش مشكله
كل واحد عنده رايه وفي كل الاحوال اصلا ما
شاء الله عليك يعني انت حلوه والقالب غالب
ولو ايش ما لبستي اصلا حلو والفستان كان
حلو وكلنا بنعيد ملابسنا فانا حبيت انك
تردي على هذا الموضوع لانه
كيف يعني بتعيد الملابس لا كلنا بنعيد
الملابس لازم نعترف بهذا الموضوع يعني طيب
لا انا انبسطت على فكره لا كان في تعليقات
كثير حلوه انه كانت الناس عم بتقول انه
بالعكس هذا الشيء حلو وانا بتقصد ايام انه
اعمل هيك شي لانه في كتير بنات يعني اوقات
كمان نحن عم نقطع بظروف صعبه يعني عنا وفي
بنات يمكن انه لا عادي مش غلط لو على
خطبتك ولا ولا مناسبه عيد ميلادك فيك
تلبسي شي لابستيه من قبل يعني
القصص سخيفه بالحياه بالنسبه لالي في قصص
في اشياء اهم بكثير فانا عم جرب يمكن اوصل
كمان رساله من خلال هذا الشيء
ممتاز جدا طيب نحن بنشكرك جدا على وجودك
معنا اليوم مريضه وبنتمنى لك كل التوفيق
ومبروك المسلسل والبطوله وان شاء الله
تكسري الدنيا وان شاء الله الفرح يكون
احلى فرح وتكوني احلى عروسه ان شاء الله
شكرا لك
ميرسي كتير انا انبسطت معكن وكل سنه وانتم
بخير وانت بخير
[موسيقى]